- Hi
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
So I spend most of my time
sitting in between these
two sleeve-less wonders.
The other day they got in a fight
about whether beer pong
or flip cup was better.
I don't care, so I'm the moderator.
But these guys are gonna have it out
to decide what's a better drinking game:
Beer Pong or Flip Cup
I'll let them give you
their drinking credentials.
- Ladies first.
- Oh thanks.
My name's Jordan.
I like to drink.
I like to have fun.
I'm not really sure what other kind
of credentials I need.
- I'm Ryan.
Chapman University 2013.
Was in a fraternity,
so I definitely know a little bit
about drinking games.
Probably more than her,
but that remains to be seen.
- So these guys both did a little research
and talked to a lot of people
to try and make a defense and a case
for their game of choice.
They're going to show
each other the footage,
they're going to show me the footage,
and we're going to let the viewers at home
decide who's in the right.
But before we do that,
we have to figure out who gets to go first
and we're going to do that
through a quick game of eye-to-eye.
- Let's do it.
- Alright.
- So quick disclaimer from Jordan.
- We realize that we're
breaking the elbow rule,
but we don't have enough space,
so get over it.
- Three. Two. One.
(beep)
Well that was great.
- You're both terrible at this.
Three. Two. One.
- Let's go. Me first.
- Alright, Ryan. Cue it up.
- Your desktop is a mess, dude.
How are you going to have
an organized argument
if you can't even have
an organized computer?
- Oh I'll show you how I
have an organized argument--
just give me a second for it to load
and then I'll show you.
(dramatic acoustic music)
Beer Pong.
The undeniable poster-child
of drinking games.
And today, I'm going to prove to you
why beer pong is the
greatest drinking game
in the world.
But, if I'm right,
and I'm definitely right,
you probably already knew that.
So to start my case,
I took to the streets of LA
to ask what was the best drinking game.
Keep in mind, these people have no idea
I'm making a video about beer pong.
In your opinion, what is
the best beer drinking game?
- The best beer drinking
game, for sure, is beer pong.
- Beer pong, it's more social.
- King's cup.
- Beer pong.
- Kings.
- This game we call "Things".
- Is that even a game?
- Recap.
That's one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight votes for beer pong,
and one, two votes for King's cup,
and also one vote for
some game called "Things".
Yes, that means a game that
I've never even heard of
got more votes than flip cup.
Which put up a big, fat donut.
You get it. Moving on.
I could show you how fun beer pong is
by showing you clips like
this epic beer pong dunk
from my college days.
(people screaming)
Shit's epic.
- That has nothing to do with beer pong,
he just belly-flopped onto a table.
- But instead, I'm just going to show you
me and my dad, chillin' over a game of BP
in the backyard.
- Does anyone in your family
have sleeves on their shirts, Ryan?
- Alright.
- Not bad for an old dude.
- Yeah, whatever.
(laughs)
You've seen this game before,
and you saw it for the first time,
one summer night, actually in this house,
when we were having a party.
- Right.
- What did you think of
when you first saw it?
- I think that night,
one of your uncles was over here,
who's about my age, and we figured,
you know what, that looks like a game
that we could proudly
school these young kids on.
I was never really into
chugging games and I figured,
well, why not play a skill game,
while having a casual sip of your beer?
I mean the two just
went together naturally.
And I believe we actually did
beat you guys all that night,
and you weren't too happy about it.
- You lost the first game
from my recollection.
- Okay, is that what it was?
I don't think there is,
like, an age requirement,
or anything like that,
pretty much anybody can play.
- Aw man, see that form dad?
(laughs)
So to close this thing out,
I sent an e-mail to the entire office
to see who would like to participate
in a beer pong tournament.
Within one hour, I had 60 volunteers.
But, due to time, I had to cut it down
to an 18 tournament.
(techno music)
Alright, let's be honest.
Nobody wants to watch the qualifiers,
so let's just skip to the finals.
(dramatic music)
- I will.
- Balls back!
- Alright.
- You go girl.
- Watch Malory with her elbows, though!
- Nice.
- Yeah!
- Okay, okay.
- You got it girl.
- Where are you going
every time for defense?
- Yeah, baby!
- See what happened?
- Well Kelsey's carrying your team.
- You got to get this one, man.
- Okay. That's a lot of pressure.
Oh!
- [Kelsey] You're there!
- Yeah baby!
- What am I doing?
- Yeah, T-Lo!
- We're falling apart.
We're falling apart.
- Finally!
Get that cup.
- That's how we do.
- No, please stop.
- Look at T-Lo.
- Oh!
- Yes!
- Hold on, I have a speech to make.
This has been a good game.
- Oh my god, stop--
- I really enjoyed this game.
- Okay. Winning an Oscar.
- Oh wait, rebuttal right?
- No rebuttal, it's the same front cup.
- Fucking horseshit.
- So what did we learn here today?
Beer pong is the crowd favorite.
It can be chill, or it can be crazy.
It can be enjoyed by people young and old
and it also lends itself
to decorum and competition,
i.e. the tournament that we just had.
And I guess that's my
favorite part about it,
the competitive aspect that
it brings out in people,
because when you step up to the table,
you would swear that you could beat
the people across from you,
no matter who they are,
and no matter how skilled you are.
I didn't make that did I?
- Almost.
- That's fine.
- So beer pong is the most popular,
and that makes it the best?
- Do you know how many people
are going to think of
the first drinking game
that comes to mind, and
just say that though?
They are clearly not well-educated
in the art of drinking games.
- Keep in mind, I asked 12 people
and not one of them said flip cup.
- Yeah, well. Just wait.
- We do agree that just,
sheer logistics, flip cup
is a simpler game for set up.
- Flip cup is perhaps a little bit more
logistically sound to set up,
however, I still think that it's more
just like savage and crazy.
If you went to a family reunion and said
"Hey, let's play this chugging game"
I don't think everybody would be on board.
- You're chugging like an ounce at a time
and if you really don't
want to be in the game,
you can be out the first round
and have only drank one ounce of beer.
[Ryan] - Well that sounds like a good game
when I don't want to play
anymore, I just leave.
- Which game do you
think takes more skill?
- Beer Pong.
[Jordan] - Beer pong.
- I think beer pong.
- Of course beer pong.
But that's why it's not
the best drinking game,
because it takes skill to have fun.
- You're saying that
flip cup's a better game
because anybody can play.
- Right.
- But that's not true.
- I think it is true.
- I think that somebody could step in
and play beer pong and have a better time
if they weren't, like,
into just craziness.
- You know what? Let's go to my argument.
And I'll stop using my words
and just show you what I mean.
- Are we ready for this?
- Yeah.
- Drinking games.
We've all probably played our fair share,
and beer pong is arguably
the most popular, right?
But is it the best?
I sure don't think so.
In fact, I think beer pong is stupid.
- That's a good point.
- [Jordan] You've got some friends over
and you decide to play
some drinking games.
You could play beer pong.
Only half the room will
get to play at a time,
and it takes what seems like forever
to finish one low energy,
boring game.
- That's a lot of adjectives
here. Not a lot of facts.
- [Jordan] Or you could play flip cup!
Everyone gets to be involved,
the energy is amped up,
and you're having a blast.
Which one sounds more appealing?
Think I'm wrong?
Let's see what the
people of LA have to say.
Beer pong or flip cup, which is better?
- Flip cup.
- I love flip cup better, yeah.
- Would you pick beer pong over flip cup?
- No, I like flip cup.
[Jordan] - You pick flip cup?
- I'm gonna say beer pong.
- Flip cup, I would say.
- I like flip cup.
- I'm better at beer pong,
so I'll say beer pong.
- In theory, I would
say, you know, beer pong.
In practice...
flip cup.
- Why?
- It's more intense, there's more people,
it's more involved.
- I think that you can really
yell a lot more in flip cup.
- Do you think that's more exciting than
just just shooting a
ping-pong ball into a cup?
- It is. It's a rush.
It's all that pressure going into it,
that's why.
- What do you have to say to that?
- I think, well, I think there's...
I don't know. There's
more competitiveness,
like, with beer pong...
- So the people of LA chose flip cup,
but do you still think beer pong
is the best drinking game?
Well we took two people
from Ryan's tournament,
and decided to see what they had to say
about the debate.
- Yes.
Oh man.
- Oh.
Down. Up. Down.
[Bald Man] Down. Up. Down.
- Flip cup. The game is over pretty fast.
I can get games in.
And a lot of people can play,
there's, like, no limit to how many people
can play in a game,
so that's really fun.
And it's teamwork.
- You got it, you got it.
- It gets everyone involved,
that's what's fun about flip cup.
- If you have a large group of people,
flip cup is more fun to play.
- It's really fun.
- Nice!
- So, what did we learn?
Well, the people who
like beer pong the best
are mostly just the
ones who are good at it.
Which doesn't make it
the best drinking game,
it just makes it the best drinking game
for sore losers with good
hand-eye coordination.
- What?
- Wow!
- What are you talking about?
- Mic drop.
- The only point you made was that
more people could play with flip cup,
which is, like, not even necessarily true.
- Did you see all the
people on the street?
It was six to three.
The more people you get involved,
the more fun it is.
It's a more high energy game,
you're not just sitting there
throwing a ping-pong ball
at a bunch of red cups.
- What parties have you been to
where beer pong is not high energy?
- I'm not even trying to say that flip cup
is the best drinking game,
because I don't necessarily
believe that either,
I just think it's better than beer pong.
- Don't agree.
- All you had to say is
"beer pong is popular" and
"people can be good at it".
- I didn't say beer pong was popular,
I said beer pong was the best.
- And then I asked people
if they'd pick flip cup
over beer pong...
- Yeah, you had to mention
the name "Flip cup" to them.
- That doesn't matter,
everybody picked flip cup.
- She's pulling a lot of muscle over here
with these stretches.
- I don't think I'm stretching anything.
Let me ask you this:
What's the point of drinking games?
- One, to socialize.
Or two, to get drunk.
- Great. So fip cup does
both of those things
- Does it though?
- Beer pong does one of those things.
- Beer pong does both of those things.
- I have never gotten drunk
during a game of beer pong.
It's too slow.
- It takes too long.
- Who are you guy playing against?
You're playing a 35 minute beer pong game,
maybe you should just not be playing
drinking games in general.
- Or maybe you shouldn't--
- Alright, alright, alright.
Let's wrap this up. Let's wrap this up.
So I think you both have presented
some pretty valid arguments here.
On Jordan's side, she's
saying that flip cup
is a more inclusive game,
that it doesn't require as much skill,
has more people, gets you more drunk,
ends a little more rowdy.
Ryan also presents a valuable argument,
which is that there's
sort of a team aspect
to beer pong, people can get dolled-up,
make their uniforms.
There's a lot of flexibility in beer pong
as to whether it's a rowdy, fratty game,
or whether it's just a casual, backyard,
hang out kind of vibe.
I feel like you both have
some pretty valid arguments.
I don't know if I am qualified
to really make this decision,
so I think we need to throw this
to the viewers at home.
- It's all up to you guys.
Make the right choice.
(upbeat rock music)